another main topic that's being
discussed in book 4 the Republic really
the most important central point has to
do with the nature of the virtues and
Plato's going to talk about four virtues
here in other works he sometimes talks
about five but here he's going to talk
about the four cardinal virtues and
we'll go over those as they come up most
important is that he's drawing a
connection between the person so an
individual and the city which is
comprised of persons all of some sort of
relation to each other and you notice
that in his ideal city he has these
Guardians he has the auxiliary guardians
and he has the tradespeople these three
classes but you wouldn't necessarily
have to have an ideal city in order to
say that you know some people who are
charged you know charged with ruling or
at least they are they're able to rule
you know some people who have the
military force who are you know engaging
in police saying who maintain order and
then you have the vast majority of other
people you know in a good City Plato
would say you want Guardians
well the rulers aren't necessarily the
best people in many cities so how does
he connect these two together is it just
well there's three and there's three so
they they fit nice no it's actually you
have to do it with the virtues and the
nature of them we should we should
actually say before we get into this
that when Plato talks about virtues he
doesn't mean what some people today mean
sometimes when people talk about virtues
they just mean you know being good or or
certain things that you can say about a
person that sound good like integrity or
honesty or or courage or things like
that
now when a lot of people talk that way
they they really have no idea what
they're saying because for the ancient
Greeks and really for most people who
talk about virtue
you know until fairly recently a virtue
means something that's part of your
character it's
who you are it's not just something that
you happen to do once in a while it's
not that by you know being generous and
giving to to a charity this time of the
month you've acquired the virtue of
generosity you need to be able to do it
reliably it has to be part of the fabric
of your personality and there's not just
virtues there's also Vice as opposed to
them bad qualities of character and
we're going to talk about those as well
so bear that in mind as we go through
this now the goal that Socrates has is
to figure out one particular virtue
namely justice but try to figure out
what it is and in Socrates is saying we
want to figure out where we would find
it in the person and in the city so
let's think about this he says I mean to
begin with the assumption that our state
if rightly ordered is is perfect and
being perfect it's there therefore going
to be wise and valiant or courageous and
temperate and just it's going to have
these virtues it's going to express
those virtues which ever these some of
these qualities we find the state the
one which is not found will be a kind of
residue so if we can locate these
virtues and the state and said well this
one belongs here this one belongs here
whatever is left over is going to be the
residue so he says we can do this with
the virtues first among the virtues
found in the state wisdom comes into
view and in this I detect a certain
peculiarities says what is that the
statement we have been describing is
said to be wise as being good and
counsel and good counsel is clearly a
kind of knowledge because when you're
giving advice to something that's a
counsel is when you're saying you should
do this or the street should run over
here or you know this should be a
federal holiday or this shouldn't be a
federal holiday presumably you're doing
so by knowledge and now which of these
classes is concerned with knowledge and
learning well it's a Guardians
so wisdoms
is going to be something that's peculiar
to the Guardians
after all they're the ones who are the
philosophers are the ones who who spend
the most time becoming educated now
there's all kinds of knowledge in the
state right it's not as if these people
don't have any knowledge these people
studies say military science or criminal
justice or policing these people have to
study all sorts of things you know when
it comes to a carpenter you want a
carpet who actually knows his job comes
to a plumber comes to a dietician you
want them to actually have knowledge so
Socrates says there's the knowledge of
the carpenter but isn't that the kind of
knowledge that gives a city the title of
wise and good and counsel the city is
not going to be called wise because
possessing a knowledge which counsels
for the best use of wood which is where
carpentry is about nor my reason of a
knowledge which advises of up raising
pots nor is possessing any other kind of
knowledge not have a cultural so what
kind of knowledge is it going to be he
says what is this knowledge and among
whom is it found it's the knowledge of
the guardians and found among those who
ridges we were just discussing now we're
going to get to looking at wisdom in a
bit more detail in the next video so
let's actually just put that up whole
point is the Guardians the smallest
class they're the ones who either have
wisdom or don't have it if things are
going right in the city they're going to
have it and operate according to it what
else well there anything that goes along
with these guys we have three virtues
justice temperance courage courage
that's needed by soldiers isn't it
that's needed by police that's needed by
anybody who would keep social order or
defend the nation the city the community
against oppressors and attackers so he
says there's no difficulty in see
the nature of courage and what part that
quality resides in which gives the name
of courageous to the state when we want
to know whether a people is courageous
we're not actually looking to the rulers
we're looking to the military people
we're looking to the people who actually
do need to exhibit courage so he says
here we go
the rest of the citizens may be
courageous or may be cowardly but their
courage or cowardice will not have the
effect of making the whole city either
the one or the other so it's the it's
whether the the Guardians have wisdom
that makes the city wise it's whether
the auxilary Guardians have courage that
makes the whole city courageous
it'll be courageous he says in virtue of
a portion of herself which preserves
under all circumstances that opinion
about the nature of things to be feared
and here we get to some discussion about
the nature of courage what is courage
for Plato it's a it includes a knowledge
of what is to be feared and it includes
a preservation as he says a saving
assault area of that he talks in in
several different parts about this
metaphor of dying not dying isn't like
being killed but dying as you know
dipping things in to die and changing
their color you know this tie for
example I could wash this tie if I
wanted to and it would retain these
brilliant you know reds and blues and
whites that are in it why because it's
been dyed the fabric itself I think this
is probably soaked 100% silk dryclean
only don't put it in a washing machine
because I'll mess up the fibers but if
this comes back from the dry cleaners
and it's now all white I'm gonna say
what happened and one of the answers
could be well the color just wasn't fast
it didn't stick so the education that
the Guardians the lesser guardians are
supposed to receive is supposed to
develop courage in them and
courage is a kind of sticking to
knowledge about what is actually to be
feared so that when an something scary
comes along they can you know and their
big fear is arising in them they can say
the fear I'm going to ignore that here's
what I need to do here's the the right
thing that has to be done so he says
we're not talking about the the
uninstructed courage of a wild beast
we're talking about the the courage that
a loft or gains the courage of a citizen
so what else do we need to talk about
well there's another virtue which is
temperance and then he says you know
that that actually does blow under the
tradespeople but really all of them want
to have it
the ones who we have to worry about the
most are the tradespeople and you know
why because they're the ones ready to be
tempted to be intemperate the most these
guys are really concerned with you know
knowledge and study I suppose they could
be a little bit intemperate with that
these guys are concerned with with
exhibiting courage and military training
these guys are the ones you got to watch
because they're gonna be the ones who
are gonna be eating and drinking more
than they should be or trainer you know
cheat on each other and seduce each
other spouses or you know tempted to lay
around or just to pile up heaps of money
so that they can buy whatever they they
want temperance
as Plato says here as the ordering or
controlling of certain pleasures and
desires he says its it involves being
your own master he says the meaning is
that in the human soul there is also a
better and a worse principle and when
the better has the worse under control
then a man is said to be master of
himself a person is said to have
self-control when in the better parts of
their soul are actually running the show
and at the worst part of their soul
so temperaments will be had in these
social classes when that's actually the
case so he says the manifold and complex
pleasures and desires and pains are the
things that we have to be concerned with
whereas you know other simple and
moderate desires that follow reason are
to be found only in a few so if the city
itself is if the entire city is going to
have temperance this part has to be
obedient to the rules it has to not go
too far it can't say you know a six-pack
was nice now we need to drink a whole
case or I'm gonna have the
all-you-can-eat buffet every single day
we can come up with all sorts of other
examples as well he says temperance is
unlike courage and wisdom each of which
resides only in one part the one making
the state wise the other courageous
temperance extends to the whole and runs
through all the notes of the scale and
produces a harmony of weaker and
stronger in the middle class whether you
suppose them to be stronger or weaker
and wisdom where numbers are wealth or
anything else
so temperance is the agreement of the
naturally superior and the inferior as
to the right to rule of either so now
what does that tell us about ourselves
well we can speak of these three virtues
as also existing in our souls existing
in our personalities existing in
ourselves courage is when this spirited
part is in good shape and we actually do
the things that are needed to do in
scary situations we don't go overboard
and go crazy and just become super
aggressive and beat everybody up but we
also don't let people down we also when
we see aggression take
place interpose ourselves if that's our
role wisdom means properly understanding
how to manage one's own affairs how to
make sense out of life and that's
something that would belong to the
rational part you're not going to get
wisdom coming out of the appetite of
part of your soul only the part that
does the thinking can actually be wise
now not everybody's going to be wise not
everybody is going to be courageous
temperance temperance is the control
over those appetites
it doesn't mean totally suppressing them
saying no in every circumstance it means
saying okay but this far not this far no
no this far stop here
it means observing certain kinds of
limits becoming more temperate might be
saying all right I understand I said
only go this far and you've gone this
far now let's try to pull it back bit by
bit but that would be the process of
becoming temperate that's when the
amputated part is actually listening to
what the rational part is telling it
about how much it should enjoy how much
it should avoid what is your desire what
it should be averse to now what about
justice we haven't found it anywhere
halfway so Socrates says the last of
those qualities which makes the state
virtuous must be justice if we only knew
what it was so now we need to figure out
where does it fit in here is it part of
the Guardians isn't part of the
auxiliaries it's part of the
tradespeople he says the time has
arrived where we need to pay close
attention you need to get on the track
like like like dogs and he says oh we've
been looking at it the whole time we
just didn't realize it
so he says remember the original
principle which we were laying down at
the foundation of the state that one
person should practice one thing only
the thing to which his nature was best
adapted now justice is this principle or
a part of it
justice was doing one's own business not
being a busy
to do one's business in a certain way
may be assumed to be justice so what
does that mean that means that in the
city the Guardians rule the tradespeople
actually they do their jobs but they
also obey that what the Guardians bit
and the auxiliaries don't go off
starting wars on their own or oppressing
the trades people or you know engaging
in palace coos they're there to enforce
the rule of the guardians on to the
tradespeople and to protect the city and
when all that occurs then you actually
have justice so justice is not something
that resides in any one single part
justice resides in the relations between
these parts notice to that you're not
actually going to be able to have
justice not much of it at least unless
these other parts are actually doing
what they're supposed to do without
wisdom if this part gets you know out of
control and it's not doing what it's
supposed to do you can't have justice
because they're gonna tell the trades
people who do the wrong things if this
part is you know going crazy and you
know being harsh and oppressive or if
it's not actually standing up for for
itself I'm doing what it needs to do
then justice won't be able to occur
either and without temperance justice is
going to be impossible as well what
about in the human being likewise
justice is going to be the virtue that
has to do with the entire person not
just one part of the person it's going
to be about the relation between these
parts and again it will be the rational
part telling the appetite apart what to
do and the spirited part adding its
strength to make sure that the appetite
of part actually obeys so what else do
we need to say about this he comes back
to this later on
and he says we cannot but remember that
the justice of the state consisted in
each of the three classes doing the work
of its own class we have to recollect
that the individual in whom the several
qualities of his nature do their own
work will be just and will do his own
work so when your three parts are
functioning properly have their virtues
and they're actually in the right
alignment with each other the right
harmony with each other then you can be
a just person so he says the United
influence of music and gymnastic that is
this kind of Education and disciplining
that he was talking about is part of
what will promote this now he also talks
a little bit later on about something
else that that's very important he says
when we're talking about the just person
what do we have in mind
he says justice is not concerned just
with the outward person it's concerned
with the inward which is the true self
and the real concern of human beings for
the just person does not allow the
several elements within them to
interfere with one another or for any of
them to do the work of the others he
sets in order his inner life and is his
own master in his own law and at peace
with himself and when he is bound
together these three principles within
him which may be compared to the higher
lower and middle notes of the scale when
he's bound these together she's no
longer many so if we want to be a fully
integrated person the goal is not just
to repress one part of our soul nor to
indulge one part of our soul the goal is
to harmonize them to understand how they
actually work that's really the job of
the rational part but it takes this
middle spirited part to make that happen
courage is not just something that you
display in relation to other people or
you know taking a stand it's something
that you take in relation to yourself
within your
personality against your baser parts
that would otherwise run the show and
rule this is a very powerful and
beautiful picture of what it means to
become an integrated human being to
realize human nature if we look at the
contrast in justice he says must not
injustice be a strife of fighting a
conflict which arises among the three
principles a meddlesome Mis and
interference a rising up of a part of
the soul against the whole an assertion
of unlawful Authority what is all this
confusion and delusion except for
injustice and intemperance and cowardice
and ignorance and every form of vice
when people are screwed up according to
Plato according to this view of human
nature when they do stupid things when
they do as we say ignorant things when
they act like jerks when they're selfish
it's coming from within from who they
are it's not just coming from society or
pressures or you know circumstances it's
coming from the fact that within them
there's a kind of conflict going on
there not a unified integrated person
they're at war with themselves and that
war spills out into the rest of the
world so he says what this is going to
lead to then is all sorts of external
acts which are they're a lot easier to
see it gives examples of this sacrilege
theft treachery breaking agreements
committing committing infidelity
dishonouring fathers and mothers failing
in our duties if we want to avoid doing
that sort of thing it's not just a
matter of like you know finding rules or
inducing fear in ourselves according to
Plato we need to actually care about our
personalities we need to care about our
souls and we need to properly exercise
and develop those part
within us that are at this point perhaps
lacking